can you tell my husband this because
he's like this is so weird that we have
to be in bed number he waits until he
thinks I'm asleep and then he throws
bunny out of bed no yeah and I get so
mad I'm like take everybody out of bed
hi I'm Margaret Robbie I'm Rami Malek
and we are going to play a game of do
you even know me do you even know me how
well do you know me no do you even know
do you even know me for uni lab
so here we go this should be helpful
but these might be yeah okay yeah but
these might be a while these might be
things that we haven't weirdly discussed
so you never know okay let's see what
let's see what we have to say then what
is my favorite book series ever
a the Twilight Saga B Fifty Shades C
Harry Potter it's Harry I know I was too
easy though too easy you knew it was
going to be too easy yeah what else you
had
do you know I did
it's a bit of a soft it's a bit of a raw
point for me but I did the test on the
Pottermore website which is the legit
one and I'm actually in Hufflepuff and I
was really upset about that to begin
with but then I read why and actually I
think yeah why why hufflepuffs are
actually very loyal friends and very
hard-working people that makes sense
I thought I got a real friend and yeah
they yeah plus Cedric Diggory was in
Hufflepuff and he's a g so
what job did I have in New York before I
became an actor
your handwriting is is interesting okay
um catching rats in the subway
making Falafel sandwiches
drawing people's portraits on the street
making Falafel sandwiches
come on no yes yeah I thought you had
that job yes
see I told you this I know this I have a
feeling that most of these she's gonna
know we'll see we'll see we'll see as a
child I went to Summer circus school
what was my specialty a juggling b
trapeze or C knife throwing juggling
incorrect but I did it was trapeze but I
did do juggling there in fact you told
me that you joking I did but trapeze was
more of my specialty oh okay how old
were you I don't know little but I I've
also done it since um really because you
know in the Santa Monica Pier you can do
trapeze there and on the pier in New
York you can do trapeze there actually I
actually love trapeze and you love the
Santa Monica pier and I love I love
Santa Monica you know I love Santa
Monica I know rollerblading
we've seen you rollerblade there
countless times yeah well now the whole
world has yeah I know they know you are
supposed they know they don't know our
drinking spots though not yet I took you
to a good one there remember oh that's
where you were going with it that was
fun okay I played Lucifer saffron in no
time to die
spell my character's name
it's not a multiple choice I know it's
not I didn't choose this I I I literally
can't okay do you want me to kind of
phonetically say it slowly for you yeah
Lucifer saffin
loot seal yes and you have to do it yes
you
l-y yes l-y-u
t
s j
t s i a it's t y e yeah
it's just wrong at that point spell
saffin
s-a-w-f-o-n okay no wrong again
s-a-f-n-i-n yes
who came up with that name uh oh
you know yeah I came up with no yeah
saffron was the name and then we had a
host of choices no because you know when
as if you just like went like this on a
keyboard
yeah oh yeah we're calling that no but
you know there's only you have to clear
names in films of course you know this
so uh there were so many that we
couldn't clear for some reason wasn't
yeah
um can you spell it for me please
because I never got to the bottom of
that you did um l-y-u-t-i
well it's like this
what do I keep with me every night in
bed a your husband
a packet of biscuits in case I get
hungry B air pods because my own snoring
wakes me up okay we'll see a stuffed toy
animal called bunny bunny yeah yeah
yeah
when did you get bunny the day I was
born bunny is very old it doesn't look
anything like it doesn't doesn't
remotely resemble a bunny rabbit anymore
she's so old but
I have my koala as well oh you do oh
good sorry do you sleep with it every
night though every night so okay and my
husband this because he's like this is
so weird that we have to be in bed
number he waits until he thinks I'm
asleep and then he throws bunny out of
bed no yeah and I get so mad I'm like
everybody out of bed ah the things bunny
has seen yeah well no I shouldn't see
that anyways is someone keeping school
by the way yes okay good because I want
to know who wins at the end of this
whoever loses has to buy the other one a
present to say sorry for not being a
better friend okay
who gives better gifts you or me
you give Drake she wins which musical
instrument have I learned to play
piano guitar saxophone piano
great easy enough am I very good no I'm
not very he's a laid piano at my house
at 4am remember that yes I have how
could I forget
all right oh don't worry about it that
was a big night what is my least
favorite food a caviar
B Tara mesolata
C dark chocolate
well I know you like caviar yeah
can you eat dark chocolate
uh do you know what tiramisalata is it's
that Greek version of some type of
caviar as well right
you don't like dark chocolate it's Tara
masalata
you going Tara masalata yeah
correct I hate terms yes why do you hate
it I don't know it's like fishy moosey
that's gross I don't know they love it
here anymore
disgusting but we do love Greece we love
everything about green I didn't even
know it was Greek yes yes all I know is
that everyone puts out as a dip and I
always think it's something else and
then I eat it and then I'm like a little
tiramis water in my mouth today
all the important things yeah ah you
know my brother Sammy how much older I
am than my identical twin
four hours four minutes four seconds
four minutes yes very well done how do
you know that we've talked about it God
yeah best memory
yeah my piano recital
um how was my character Donna Friedman
written out of Neighbors a she was
uh killed by a shark in a shark attack
whilst on vacation
B she stole all her family's money and
went to live in Hawaii okay see she went
to New York to enroll in fashion design
school
well as an avid fan of neighbors you've
seen old 300 something episodes yes in
fact I've watched them twice 600.
it's clearly fashion School
you're right yes how did you know that
have I told you that no but no yeah
someone else told me that actually
really yeah I actually asked to be
killed off and they said no we want to
keep it open so when things are if
things don't work out when things don't
work yeah you could come right back your
job back and I was like I'm gonna make
it
who was also oh who was all also in my
musical theater class back in high
school Kirsten Dunst Paul Rudd Andy
Kaling
oh this is hard
Paul Rudd yeah
well I've lost it already but out of
curiosity
no yeah that's so cool very cool yeah
wow immediately you could see I was like
okay I get it yeah this person's pretty
special wow yeah
in my opinion
what is the best prank I pulled as a
child a put a fart cushion under my
teacher's chair and was never found out
B put gravy in the shower head at home
so my brother had a nasty shower C faked
my own death for a babysitter
if you would have done all of these
things
it's gravy with your brother isn't it
I faked my own deaths did you really I
really didn't like the babysitter no
[ __ ] the story of that it's a great
story I'll tell you after come on do you
want to hear it now do we have time well
our usual babysitter Talia who was like
a high school student and I adored her
so much uh my mom maybe she had exams or
something I'm not sure but my mom got
another babysitter in this old lady and
she was really grumpy and mean and I was
so pissed off that we didn't have Talia
anymore and um and in defiance I was
just not going to listen to anything
this old mean lady babysitter had to say
she was like go have your bath and I was
like No just like go take a bath and I
was like um
you are going to pay for this in my head
I said that and then I went and I took a
giant kitchen knife and ketchup and I
lay naked on the tiles outside the
bathroom covered myself and catch up and
put the knife next to me and I lay there
I like I committed I lay there for 40
minutes on these cold tiles and I
remember thinking like she has got to
come check on me soon it's very
irresponsible actually for her not to
come check soon but eventually she did
come and I almost gave her a heart
attack anyway she didn't come back she
didn't come back
very dramatic all right do you want some
I think we have to run now yeah but who
won I don't know keep going keep going
last one no actually I think that's okay
that's good that's it
okay who do you think won
I think Margo won I think
I'll buy you a presents I'll buy you a
present
yeah that was very fun love that
apologize for my handwriting no not at
all
what was the name of the character I
played in the Star Wars prequels he
princesses
princess princess
I love you
princess
boba tea
that's a good name